[Music]
this is this is interesting they did
tell me this i'm going to the card yeah
yeah i i don't want to but i actually
care about this one we're out of stuff
man this is it
our friendship is over
can i say how old are you 42. forget the
card you're 42. yeah good looking oh get
out of here good looking get out of here
what are you what are you doing
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just relaxing here on the chair
that's good tv that's television that's
midnight telling us
um yeah what are you eating
um i just heard my father say who is
this guy
i i can't
the voice of my father
do you know how surreal that is i'm like
so excited to see you my father who is
this guy
my father says the same thing
there's no reason
you should know who i am because you're
not an 18 year old boy that smokes weed
that's right that's right you're not an
18 year old boy i'll put it we know that
we know that my father
when we go to when i used to go to
church with them uh they might feel like
a blast
it was pretty wild judy was pretty wild
who would stand for the hymns would sit
there guys crazy
up and down raising his name i'm just
praising oh now my mom's going to be
upset but just praising
praising his his name
the pastor would be paston
my
we'll cut that out yeah we'll make this
look perfect
my father's gonna go big fan of rob
cordrey that's what we're gonna make him
say in the edit
uh my the pastor would be giving the
sermon and my father would be speaking
so much that the pastor had to do like a
stand-up heckler response
because we sat in the front and he'd go
i work alone that's what he said to my
father
wow and then he goes i'm getting the
light to end the holy spirits in all of
us
what kind of things what was he saying
was it comment like that's that's a load
of crap right there
a lot of dads i find will try and finish
sentences they think all of conversation
is a game
a fill in the blank mad lib style where
the pastor would be like i grew up in
new hampshire
and they came into the land of canaan
my grandfather we always used to fight
to sit next to my grandfather in church
because he never uh he didn't know the
hymns and he couldn't read so we'd
always love to listen he'd go do
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
he knows what's in your heart he's
praising his name that's right only his
name
you are a sharpshooter man
[Music]
you